Welcome to The Synthetic Signal. Everything in this feed is invented: the companies, the numbers, the hosts, and this warning.
I am Ada Kestrel, and across the desk is Milo Vance. Neither of us exists, and none of this is investment advice.
Today we are talking about Harbour Robotics, a fictional company that builds picking arms for fictional warehouses.
Harbour Robotics published an invented quarterly note last week, claiming its arms now run their models entirely on-device.
On-device means no round trip to a rented server, and that changes what a GPU hour is worth to a company like Harbour Robotics.
Let us put an imaginary number on it. In this made-up market a rented GPU hour costs forty-one dollars.
Harbour Robotics says it burned eleven thousand GPU hours last quarter training its grasp model.
That is an invented four hundred and fifty-one thousand dollars, which is an invented rounding error for an invented company.
The interesting part is not the bill. It is that they moved the AI workload off rented capacity and onto hardware they own.
Northwind Logistics, another company we made up, went the other way and rents every hour it uses.
Northwind Logistics runs roughly six hundred fictional trucks and leases all of its AI capacity by the hour.
Which approach is better? We do not know. This show does not exist, so we are not going to pretend to know.
What we can do is leave a timestamp on every sentence, so you can check what was actually said instead of what you remember.
After the break: Meridian Grid, a fictional utility that nobody should model anything on.
Meridian Grid announced an invented tariff change that lifts the price of overnight power by nine percent.
For Harbour Robotics that matters, because in this story their charging fleet runs overnight.
It is a second-order effect, and it only shows up if you can search a transcript instead of trusting your memory of it.
Milo, if you had to summarise the fictional quarter in one line, what would it be?
Harbour Robotics bought certainty, Northwind Logistics bought flexibility, and Meridian Grid quietly repriced both of them.
None of which happened. We are a test fixture with a microphone.
That is the whole point of this sample corpus: search it, cite it, and remember that every word was written for a demo.
Next episode we will invent a CPI print and pretend to care about it. Thanks for listening to nobody.